continúan las labores de rescate en
coahuila casi 400 rescatistas operan sin
cesar para dar con los 10 mineros que
quedaron atrapados en un pozo de carbón
el pasado miércoles en las últimas horas
lograron duplicar la capacidad para
extraer el agua que inundó el pozo pero
el nivel baja lentamente porque mientras
el agua sale por un lado entra por otro
por lo que los socorristas aún no
consiguen ingresar a la mina lo que ya
hay mucho
[Música]
más de evacuación de agua
y aquí lo importante que la gente
preguntaba
qué será
la coordinación nacional de protección
civil informó que el personal que
trabaja en el rescate introdujo una
cámara en uno de los pozos para evaluar
las condiciones de la mina por su parte
la fiscalía del estado de coahuila dijo
que había entrevistado a los cinco
trabajadores que lograron escapar de la
mina y que su oficina había solicitado
información al propietario del terreno y
al concesionario pero los lentos avances
hacen que los familiares de los
damnificados
empiecen a perder la paciencia y las
esperanzas
si es difícil el es difícil
ver tanto sentimiento de preocupación de
tristeza coahuila la principal región
productora de carbón de méxico ha
sufrido una serie de accidentes mineros
mortales a lo largo de los años